oscar-winner Russell Crowe is a long way
away from his gladiator days in his
latest role Crowe is giving us crazy
details behind his epic TV
transformation into controversial
FoxNews exec Roger Ailes television is
the most powerful force in the world I
used to call it face jail it's war
Crow's transformation into the late news
boss initially took six hours of makeup
and the Showtime shoot lasted seven
months Sienna Miller plays Rogers wife
then she was four hours in the makeup
chair to change shape and she ages quite
significantly it's so seamless each day
you look at the former Fox News anchor
gretchen carlson is portrayed by Naomi
Watts the loudest voice deals in part
with Carlson's sexual harassment
accusations that eventually forced Ailes
to leave box he's a bully Carlson was at
the New York premiere for the limited
series it's gonna bring attention as for
any blowback from Fox News Crowes not
worried they will just be sitting back
thanking us for the advertising I mean
this has Emmy written all over at the
loudest voice premieres Sunday night on
Showtime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]